la toile de jouy entre dans une nouvelle
ère eric langlois jova sien depuis 15
ans a décidé de lancer en janvier
dernier un t-shirt sur ce thème on y
retrouve des coussins des plateaux des
torchons des choses sont inspiré des
célèbres motif de bach comme feu datant
du xviiie siècle je suis un passionné
d'art décoratif je connais le musée j'ai
visité la boutique j'ai apprécié
énormément tous les produits qu'on y
trouvait je me suis tout simplement dit
que pour moi internet représentait une
opportunité formidable de faire
connaître toute cette richesse
patrimoniale au plus grand nombre une
passion soutenu par le musée de la toile
de jouy la structure a signé un
partenariat avec l'entrepreneur pour
commercialiser les mêmes produits dans
sa boutique et sur le site internet
c'est quelque chose qu'on attendait avec
impatience parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
la boutique au musée mais de nombreuses
personnes qui suivent notre page
facebook ou ou des gens qui sont venus
puis reparti nous demander mais est-ce
qu est-ce qu on peut trouver des objets
de la boutique en dehors de la boutique
du musée le eshop compte à ce jour deux
mille visites par mois avec un panier
moyen de 50 euros pour rendre les
produits encore plus attractif éric
lenglos à travailler avec des blogueuses
l'idée est de moderniser les motifs il
faut à la fois faire des produits qui
sont des classiques mais il faut aussi
revisiter le classicisme en ajoutant des
touches modernes par exemple ce qui se
fait beaucoup c'est d'ajouter une touche
fluo dans un objet de décoration par
exemple mais on est en train par exemple
actuellement de créer
des nouveaux produits des coussins et
des foulards à partir de motifs
historiques inédits prochain objectif
eric langlois espère développer les
exportations à travers la france est
pourquoi pas dépasser les frontières de
l'hexagone pour atteindre le public
asiatique